hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the match magnus cross and versus
wesley so
uh in the first game magnus was able to
win a very nice game then wesley bounced
back after that brilliant queen to h5
move and forcing a completely winning
end game
and now we again have a tied match two
more games to go today and
let's see what happens in game three as
games seem to be
getting well crazier and crazier by the
move so here magnus with the white
pieces again
uh opens with c4 like in the first game
so the english is on the board we have
e5 knights to c3 and now
knight to f6 we have knight to f3 and
knight to c6
and again we have the four knights of
the english much like in the first game
we have d3 and now d5 striking in the
center we have c
captures on the e5 knight captures and
the now e4
attacking this knight asking do you want
to move the knight away maybe knight
back to f6
you can go to b6 or do you want to
capture on on c3 so this is exactly what
wesley does we have knight captures in
c3
b captures on c3 and now bishop to c5 we
have bishop to e2 and the both players
now castle so castles castles and
we reach a very interesting position uh
where wesley plays king to h8
and now we reached a position that was
uh played in 1986 between none other
than mikhail tal and alexander chernin
uh the game ended in a draw tile
continue with rook to b1
uh and interestingly rook the b1 is the
top move recommended by the engine and
of course
stall knew this in 1986 so you know no
no wonder uh but here magnus improves on
this with bishop to e3 so
it is already as a move tender we have a
completely new game
uh so let's see how wesley deals with
this he decides to capture an e3
uh it seems like a good idea because you
double uh white spawns but
on the other hand uh you will allow
white
to have support for the d4 push in the
future d
the e3 pawn will allow this idea
so queen to e7 uh and now queen to c2 by
magnus we have
f5 uh and now that the center is being
attacked
knight to d2 so now if captures this can
be captured by the knight and you don't
have to
further ruin your pawn structure so
bishop to e6 and
now d4 by magnus now threatening d5 to
win some material here as it would come
with a double attack on the bishop and
on the knight so here bishop to g5 by
wesley
and now saying okay if you push the pawn
i'm just going to capture on e3 with
check and pick up the bishop or even if
you block with the rook then i'm just
going to capture on e4
and it's a really really bad position
yes you are attacking uh
here but my rook and queen are attacking
your rook and f2 so your
your position just falls apart so
instead after queen to g5 rook to f3 by
magnus now keeping an eye on the e3 pawn
and now
f captures an e4 uh er getting ready to
remove the the defender of the e3 pawn
so knight captures first uh with an
attack on wesley's queen queen to h6 and
now
rook to e1 saying okay now if you
capture on f3 i can capture back with
the bishop and then the e3 pawn will be
nicely defended
so instead after rook to e1 we have b6
uh and now we have knight to f2
uh so what do you play here we have
knight to e7 now the knight
is coming into the game uh maybe via f5
maybe a g6 maybe via d5
uh who knows so here queen to e4 by
magnus now you have to be careful if you
trade
the rook here then first you're going to
lose this one with check and then
uh magnus will win the other one so you
don't want to do something like that
so e captures on d4 we have c captures
on d4 now
magnus has a past e pawn it's very uh
far away but
at some point the queen might move and
the pawn might start marching forward
so rook f the e8 end now comes queen to
e5 attacking the c7 pawn so knights to
d5 now
at the defending with the knight and the
rook now nicely defends the bishop here
bishop to b5 by magnus now attacking the
rook and
basically baiting wesley's next move so
rook the e7 and now bishop to c6 with an
attack on the knight
on the rook and saying uh okay now you
you move this rook and it doesn't really
matter where you're going to move it
because you will lose this knight and if
you play something like rook here then
just bishop captures on d5
of course is enough for a win because
after rook captures
rook to f8 to check uh we're gonna have
to block with the bishop and then queen
captures
on d5 and that's it so this is kind of
the main idea
wesley defends against all of this by
playing bishop to g8 he now exposes
carlson's queen to the attack from the
rook on e7
but this is exactly what magnus wanted
as now we reach the position from the
thumbnail and the magnus plays queen
captures on e7 he gives up the queen for
two rooks and
it's uh it's gonna be a great game from
uh from this moment on
so knight captures on e7 we have bishop
capture 78
and now uh queen to d6 wesley
centralizes the queen and now he has to
mobilize his other pieces because if
those two rooks become
active it could be could be very very
dangerous so bishop back to e4 by magnus
and
now c5 uh basically aside from the
from the active pieces magnus does have
these a very strong two pawns so
wesley would very much like to exchange
some of them so rook to d1 but
now wesley doesn't uh trade here or even
captures an a2 wesley decides to play c4
and this is maybe
maybe a bit too much but you know who
are who are we to say such things
and now you allow magnus to keep his uh
two connected
central pass pawns so he goes bishop
back to b1
now this will be protected after the
pawn is pushed wesley pushes it
and now d5 and this is now uh
already a very nicely advanced pass pawn
of course it can be captured whatever
captures this pawn just e4
and this is winning for white so instead
after d5 we have b5 now wesley wants to
start
advancing his other pawns but now knight
the e4 attacking the queen so the queen
has to move and now
bishop to c2 of course you cannot allow
pawn to c2
so bishop to c2 and now comes knight
captures on d5 but now uh although you
won a pawn you allow magnus a very
interesting idea and that is rook to f8
so rook to f8 with the idea of just
capturing on d5 the bishop will not be
able to move
so here we have knight the e7 just going
back with the knight and the defending
the bishop here
uh but uh you you could just play
something like queen to e7 and attack
the rook because uh what
happens next really can't be stopped you
have to allow this captures captures and
rook captures on d5
and hope that your queen will be able to
fight against bishop knight and rook as
you do have some pawns here so
you know maybe maybe it's possible uh
but instead after rook to f8
knight to e7 was played but now magnus
gets his other rook to the back rank
rook d to d8 now uh and it's
uh it's not easy holding this yes the
knight guards the bishop but
bishop to b3 is coming there's no
stopping that so here h6 you have to
create some breeding room for the king
but now knight the d6 even not bishop to
b3 right away
although it looks uh very very
impressive c2 is is much too powerful
now you don't really have a way of
dealing with this and now if you of
course just played this then
we get a queen into the game with check
and even this captures captures and
captures with chuck king the h7
is not enough now you can't capture the
pawn because the rook is hanging and the
next move we are getting a queen into
the game
so bishop to b3 although is a plan
uh for uh some occasion not it's not a
plan for this occasion so knight to d6
now
and here magnus has a very very clear
idea planned uh because there's uh well
not much you can do if you just continue
pushing the knight to f7 is made in one
uh the bishop cannot capture and this
bishop guards h7 so there's that
so wesley of course has to prevent this
wesley defends it by playing g6 he
creates more breeding room for the king
but now magnus has a move that
completely destroys black's position
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this
incredible move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
uh piling up on the defender of the g8
uh
square and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's knight the
c8
as usual the strongest move is always
you you know how it goes
uh so knight the c8 and now the threat
is just uh you know we eliminate the
defender of the
of the bishop here and then rook
captures here is enough to win the game
and there's no way a good way to stop
this uh so uh here
queen to e5 was played going after the
e3 pawn
uh and although you could allow this by
playing knight captures and queen
captures
there's no reason to do this the then
you allow check and then you know
the black wing can keep checking you so
magnus calmly defends it with king to f2
so king the g7 by wesley and pins now so
the bishop can move but now magnus has
to eliminate
the uh the uh knight so knight captures
on e
on e7 uh we have bishop to f7 if you
if you don't play this if you play queen
captures on e7 then rook capture sanji 8
again
is very deadly king f7 we're gonna play
bishop captures on g6 and after the king
moves
uh you will very slowly but surely win
that queen so king here king to e5 now
we're just gonna
attack the queen and that's it so
instead after knight captures an e7
bishop the f7 was played now not
allowing rook captures or knight
captures bishop here
but knight captures on g6 now and again
if you capture here then we get rook to
g8 you win this
you win the bishop and that's it two
rooks and the bishop of course will
will triumph over a queen so queen the
e6 by wesley
and now comes bishop to b3 now attacking
the queen and the bishop on f7 so queen
to f6
with check we have knight back to f4 and
now queen to h4 with check hoping for g3
to get queen captures on h2
but magnus of course just advances the
king and now bishop captures mb3a
captures in c2
wesley now incredibly close to uh
queening his c
pawn but magnus says not a problem rook
the g8 to check king h7
rook hey cher king g7 rook d g8 check
king to f7 and now rook to f8 to check
and now
uh whatever you play simply uh it simply
doesn't work if you go here then knight
g6 check
wins the black queen uh so king the g7
was played hoping for a repetition of
moves
maybe maybe it's possible but here
magnus
after king to g7 uh played a very
interesting move and that is knights the
e6 check
and he was in this position on 47 that
wesley so resigned to the game as now
there is nothing more to be done here
uh point is uh there's only one good one
move aking to g6 and now we
continue going after the king we're
going to play rook to g8 if if you go
here rook to g7 is
checkmate so you have to bring the king
down the board you have to play king to
h5 but now
g4 with check and the point is after
captures and captures
black even gets a second queen into the
game but it's not enough because knight
to f4 or knight to g7
will now be checkmate so really an
impressive game
uh game three goes to magnus he now
leads the match three two one
and the wesley will have his chance to
bounce back in the fourth game with the
white pieces again
uh to tie the match and go fresh into
the second day so we'll see what happens
uh so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank david kimura
nigel holloway happy birthday gavin
leander
uh motherson and uh happy birthday ccp
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
quarterfinals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day